what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Spider-Man no way home
could have been very very different
specifically in regards to Aunt May her
death and who killed her as it turns out
originally Mysterio was supposed to kill
Aunt May and we do have the storyboard
footage of this what this scene would
have been like now many people after
Spider-Man far from home took place
believe that Mysterio wasn't actually
dead after all it is Mysterio he is the
master of Illusion it would make perfect
sense that his own death was indeed also
an illusion in that he would come back
in Spider-Man no way home and according
to one of the storyboard artist Phil and
Gunn who released this storyboard
footage said that this scene was
actually going to be very very brutal in
regards of Spider-Man's retaliation to
Mysterio killing Aunt May so let's go
ahead and look at this footage and break
it down after but keep in mind this is
where Aunt May is already dead
foreign
now Phil posted this to his Instagram
and this is what he said under the
caption for the Post he said this
version happened under an elevated train
next to Peter's school J.J Jameson is a
TMZ style Street reporter part of the
idea being explored was Spidey is one of
the strongest superheroes but he holds
back because he doesn't want to kill
anyone but what would it sort of look
like if Spidey went Berserker mode kind
of never finished but was fun to play
with there's another half to this where
Spidey wails on the Fishbowl so as you
can see here in this first part Peter
sees Aunt May Lane on the ground he's in
full Spider-Man costume he goes up to
her thinking that she's just hurt we see
captions on the bottom where he says
Aunt May then he quickly realizes that
she's in fatal condition or already dead
and yells for help he yells somebody
help then in the background appears
Mysterio and he watches as Peter Mourns
over Aunt May's death who Mysterio is
responsible for he just murdered her so
clearly Mysterio is there to not only
prove the point but then to finish off
Spider-Man as well Peter says may a
couple of times soon realizing that
she's gone and here's something that is
really interesting Peter actually
realizes that Mysterio is there because
he quickly turns around and just runs at
him now of course Peter has his spidey
sense so when Mysteria arrives he knows
that he's there he knows Mysterio is
standing behind him and despite his
sense probably tells him that it is
Mysterio as well so he probably knows
exactly what has happened in this scene
Mysterio killed Aunt May we even see in
some of these sketches some markings
alongside of Peter's head kind of like
their waves and this is the waves of
what Spider-Man's Spidey senses are how
they would be shown on screen or as
Peter calls it his tingle so he turns
around charging at Mysterio Mysterio
fires a blast at him Peter Dodges it by
jumping to the ceiling and then he
swings in and kicks mystery ethereal and
here we see him just absolutely beat him
down he just starts wailing on him he
kicks him up against the wall then he
grabs him throws him to the ground picks
him back up throws him on the wall again
then he grabs him and throws him across
the room through a wall when Mysterio
finally tilts his head up Spidey slings
a web at him and pulls him back to him
when he gets back to Spidey he bashes
him into the ground from midair with two
of his hands from here we see him yell
we're seeing full Spider-Man Berserker
mode we're seeing all of the rage
nothing held back he grabs him again
throws him instantly webs him again and
kicks him into a truck and this is where
we see JJJ along the sidelines with his
film crew filming the whole entire thing
so this is how that would have tied in
with the whole Spider-Man being a
villain being a menace of course there's
a lot of people that are still probably
going to believe that Mysterio was kind
of right here so of course JJ being
there and filming the whole thing would
be just overall terrible for Spider-Man
because he's in full Berserker mode
people would have still thought Mysterio
would have been dead but then it would
have been revealed that he was alive but
Peter then weld on him to try and kill
him again so Peter would have really
been made out to be the villain here and
it sort of ends with Mysterio just
laying on the ground but as Phil stated
in his Instagram post there was going to
be more that was never finished that
showed Spider-Man just bashing
mysterious Fishbowl in and I'm assuming
that it would break pretty easily so
essentially they would see Spider-Man
bashing the head in of Mysterio
completely just obliterating his face
and who knows maybe he might have even
gone on to actually kill Mysterio in
this alternate story that might have
actually been why they took this part
out yes they want to test the limit of
Peter Parker being one of the strongest
superheroes and not killing but still it
might have been kind of hard to see
Spider-Man just completely bashing
somebody's face in but that would have
been kind of a cool way to add Mysterio
into the story now it would have
completely changed the movie and we
actually don't know if this would have
been indeed the same Mysterio that Peter
Parker had fought before that everybody
thought was dead this could have
actually been a variant of Mysterio from
Another Universe he could have come
through much like the other villains did
in the actual movie this would kind of
be in line with what the Green Goblin
did because of course in the actual film
he killed me however this would have
kind of changed the ending now of course
the other two Spider-Man would have been
in the film they would have still
brought Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
back they still would have had that
scene on top of the building where they
all meet because this still happens
after Aunt May dies so her death was
really the pivotal part and most
important part that kind of brought this
scene together however one thing that
would have been extremely important
about this that I don't think Marvel
would have lucked out is Aunt May
telling Peter with great power comes
great responsibility or you know her own
iteration that we got in the movie but
that is one of the most important scenes
in the entire film not only did she kind
of take the place of Uncle Ben right
here something that some fans are really
upset about out but this also gave Peter
that line that the other two Spider-Man
could bond with him over the famous
Spider-Man and Uncle Ben and now on
mayline but how would this have changed
the end well for starters the Green
Goblin wouldn't be the main antagonist
of the movie it probably would have
still remained Mysterio and there are
elements of this that could have been
really cool to see there would have been
a little bit more of a connection to
Mysterio since he was the villain of the
last movie he pretended to care about
Peter he pretended to be his mentor and
he also kind of robbed Tony Stark a
little bit so there would have been a
little bit more connection there however
we would have also missed out on the
amazing acting that Willem Dafoe did as
the Green Goblin and the fight scene
that we got before Aunt May died with
the Green Goblin and Spider-Man was
amazing we saw a lot of great
hand-to-hand combat there and we really
saw Spider-Man make good use of his webs
plus they had to figure out how to cure
him they had to figure out how to cure
the Green Goblin and this was a big part
for the emotionality of Peter Parker the
Green Goblin killed Aunt May so healing
him was something that was really hard
for him to do but ultimately at the end
he ended up doing it because Spider-Man
is a good guy Peter Parker does have
morals he does have standards it's one
of the great reasons why we love Peter
Parker Spider-Man so I think the way the
story played out was the better way but
this was really interesting to see so
let us know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below do you think
this would have been cool to see or do
you like how it originally played out
let us know and don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof